all right the goal of this video is to
go through a conversation that I just
had with research GPT by siace at types
set. to demonstrate some capacities of
this model and also learn about active
inference ants and Beyond the prompts
that I wrote will be read and answers
will only be overviewed pause the video
or see the sharable conversation Link in
the video description for Fuller text so
I jumped right in with the prompt
provide a comprehensive account of the
relationship between active inference
and the free energy principle it
provided five relevant citations and so
I wondered about this in the context of
developing a PhD dissertation around the
philosophical articulations of active
inference and the free energy principle
to go beyond just literature search and
see if it could output a full
dissertation it searched and again
returned a list of five papers which was
not exactly what I was looking for but
they are relevant
papers I then pulled into a more
beginner or learner line of questioning
can you provide a bullet point list of
the 31 most important terms for my total
comprehensive understanding of active
inference it could be technical
metaphysical pragmatic or whatever kind
of terminology is going to catalyze this
Today's starting point of my curiosity
and the terms that it recommended were
active inference free energy principle
basy and brain predictive coding marov
blanket variational free energy
generative model surprise Precision
belief updating epistemic action entropy
predictive error perceptual inference
hierarchical models action selection
propri acception affordances embodied
cognition neurophenomenology decision
Theory optimal control theory
homeostasis allostasis interception
empirical base metacognition cognitive
dissonance in activism sensory
attenuation phenomenal
Consciousness I wrote seeing all these
terms makes me truly excited however I
am not sure where or how to begin based
upon evidence supported techniques and
learn learning theory can you write me a
pseudo code loop that I can follow
during the day while I study active
inference it provided the pseudo code
the study session is initialized and
three study sessions occur per day
during each study session start with A
Brief Review focus on one key term or
concept read and understand the concept
apply Active Learning techniques
reflecting and mind maps relate the New
Concept to an already learned concept
test understanding take a short break
repeat with a new concept or deepen
understanding of the same concept and
the session reflect and plan take a
longer break to help with memory
consolidation increment the study
session and reflect and plan at the end
of the day optional to engage in related
discussions or online forums for
Community
Learning and that is
explained excellent already I feel my
confidence increasing and veilance
rising and I did can you provide
citations that address specifically
professionally how active inference and
reinforcement learning are similar and
different several extremely relevant
papers including probably the most
relevant paper are provided so five
relevant papers great work those are
some of the right citations for us to
consider can you summarize similarities
and differences between active inference
and reinforcement learning I am looking
for a bullet point list that contains as
many lines as needed such that every
line is composed to be semantically
univocal and among lines the entire
semantic space of the best possible
answer is surveyed thank you and a list
was provided with similarities seven of
them and 11 differences between active
inference and reinforcement learning one
could probably quibble or update or lump
or split but overall it did really
well so I wanted to turn to the ant
colony setting given all the above and
alluding to contemporary discourse on
applied Act of inference can you write
me 23 specific situations where testable
hypotheses arise from bare observation
of ant colony behavior and 23 situations
were provided different situations that
ant colonies engage in trail formation
division of labor brood sorting so
on I wrote Let's delve into idea 7 nest
building this concept is very
interesting to me and a few of my
nestmates as well can you do literature
meta analysis into ant nest building and
report back with an elegant blend of the
most cited papers and the most relevant
ones papers were returned 10 papers were
returned I don't know which ones are
highly cited and which ones are relevant
there were some cut off answers but
broadly speaking this looks pretty
relevant since it's dealing with
empirical and review work on ant nests
so I wrote great can you write out the
comprehensive pseudo code for starting
out an agent-based active inference
model which captures most of the
relevant terminology from all the ant
papers above and it did this the ant
Behavior studies parameters were
initialized the ant agent was
defined in terms of its perception of
the environment and action selection
sense making and decision- making that
is based upon minimization of free
energy of course it's not fully written
out here in the pseudo code but that's
something that one could go further into
a discussion with model or use
standardized
methods action performance and
communication initialization running the
simulation updating the
environment optional introduction of
environmental
changes and maybe a finalized simulation
routine that summarizes or gives
visuals excellent I'm excited about this
pseudo code which I summarized as an
active inference model of within within
and among task switching extra word
there as being like the semantic konel
or strange attractor of my
PhD I'm going to provide you my first
ideas for this seven chapter
dissertation I'm thinking of after
describing this sketch to you and
absolutely including all of the above
discussion we've had please
comprehensively expand this into a table
where the columns are chapter number
chapter name chapter goal and chapter
methodology
first chapter more about literature
review use social task allocation and
active inference second chapter
proposing mathematical framework for
infra ANS task allocation third chapter
developing a more physiological grounded
extension for future integration with
multiomic data fourth chapter is a
collaboration with friend Who develops
secure autonomous video deployments
where we create a cheap and eco-friendly
neuromorphic ant colony Behavior
recording device that fits inside of a
small backpack fifth chapter explicitly
tackles the metaphysical and onto
linguistic dimensions of the project
sixth chapter describes the synthetic
intelligence system enabling all the
chapters in terms of requirements
engineering seventh and final chapter
encapsulates the entire dissertation
with several important discussions
connections and insights otherwise
inappropriate for the six previous
chapters and it provides those
chapters six of them in a
table I wrote wonderful please improve
this table so that the existing insights
are crystallized any missing relevant
features are added and also add a new
column for chapter relevance as
distinctly articulated from chapter
goal the chapter relevance column was
provided and it does seem to differ from
the
goal and now just to close out this
conversation and video I wrote last
question for now can you come up with 27
hilarious possible titles for the
overall project ideally including some
acronym which spells out an ant related
pun from the full technical title go
wild thank you and I'll just read out
the puns Antics btics antidote antsy
antenna neuro Antics I ant intelligent
Ant Farm analytic Quant an sin antic
infra ant anticipate mbul an ant Venture
cogn ant wander ant Dina ant Converse an
frantic
benevolent elegant Fon an
consultant omnis an demsin ant ramp ant
these titles blend humor with technical
aspects of your project incorporating
ant related puns and acronyms that
reflect the essence of your research in
a playful manner so this is just a first
pass on the research GPT
tool looks like great work by the SI
base team and just very interesting and
exciting as we all head into this
scientific environment together all
right see you around the Institute
bye